us is written and directed by Jordan
Peele and it's his follow up to get out
which was excellent and extremely
surprising I love whenever someone takes
a different career path and you would
expect like when Jim Carrey was like in
Truman Show and eternal sunshine back to
back I was like this is not what I
expected from Ace Ventura and get out
was definitely not what I expected from
noise but I'm glad that we got that
because I loved his sketches on Comedy
Central but to see him become what he's
become
and what he's giving to film and the
horror genre especially it's just been a
joy the film stars Lupita and Jung go
and Winston Duke though the mother and
father of two young kids trying to have
a relaxing vacation that is cut short
when a family that looks exactly like
them shows up outside of their house and
begins to wreak havoc on their lives you
guys know me I'm a big horror fan it's
my favorite genre i fucking love horror
movies give me all the horror I wanted I
want them all right now just let me have
them all the good ones people need to
make good horror
people need to watch good horror people
need to support this genre and it's
something I'm very passionate about and
hopefully one day I can contribute to
myself and it's something I'm really
excited about and I got to say I am just
so happy that Jordan Peele is making
movies like this this film was fucking
awesome get out was so surprising and so
different but also just so goddamn
entertaining and he wasn't Oscar for the
screenplay and so coming off of that
obviously there's some pressure to see
what you do and I'm happy that he didn't
change himself you know like he didn't
become some pretentious version of what
he already was doing so well us is more
of a pure horror film than get out was
get out had a lot of social commentary
it was very funny this film has both of
those as well but it has a lot more of
the horror stuff there's a lot of blood
people creep around hallways holding
fireplace pokers so it's definitely a
horror movie it has all the things that
a genre fan would want out of a film
like this brutal kills lots of blood and
incredible score I'm amazed this is only
this composers second score get out
being his first for film anyway
according to his IMDB it's so good I
want to buy
it I want to listen to it I like to
listen to horror movie soundtracks if
I'm writing horror it kind of puts me in
the mood gets me in that field you know
what I mean and this is definitely one
of those that I would like to buy and
listen to over and over but it stands
out because of the fact that the film
can be interpreted in so many different
ways there are some aspects of the movie
that are very obvious that tell you
what's happening but then there's a lot
of it that is ambiguous and it's
definitely a film that on second viewing
you're going to appreciate more and I
can't wait to see it again I'm gonna go
see it again this weekend with my
friends because I want to look at it
through a different lens and I want to
try to examine some of the imagery that
peel's shows in the film and and what
he's going for because there's aspects
to it that are you can look at it I'm
trying so hard not to spoil it and I
won't don't worry you can look at the
film a certain way and accept what it is
the first time you watch it and it works
in that way but you can also view it
from a from a certain lens and I really
love that I love movies that evolve when
you watch it again
and I am so excited to do that because
this film begs that it really wants you
to think about the film and to have a
conversation because there's a lot of
ways you can view the movie it can be an
allegory for duality it can be an
allegory for how we view other people
you know what is our perception of the
enemy is the enemy within our own selves
or is it someone else how do we
personify what we view as an enemy and
this movie has a really clever way of
exploring those questions but like I
said purely from just a filmmaking
standpoint the movies really
well-rounded Lupita Nyong'o is
incredible in the movie she is so damn
good in this film that the Oscars will
just ignore her and she will not receive
a nomination that's how good she is in
the film I say that because Toni
Collette was so good in hereditary the
best performance I saw last year and she
did not receive a nomination but this
this could break the trend of the
Academy historically ignoring horror
films as a genre because it just I
like it might and really everyone in the
film is terrific the family has to
portray you know the main characters as
well as this doppelganger family and
they're so different
Winston Duke also putting aside the fact
that everyone plays a dual role his
character has to be scared while also
being really goddamn funny throughout
the whole film and he pulls it off and
that's another thing I loved about this
movie is that the way the comedy is
interwoven throughout it often times and
scary films a character will pause to
make a joke in the middle of a scene
you're like really man like you that
wasn't funny
like someone wrote that and made you say
it'd be better but in this film the
comedy really worked because it felt
like a family dealing with this insane
horrendous situation and then taking a
breather and observing how purely
bizarre it is and just just having to
acknowledge the humor in it and I
thought that it just worked perfectly I
have really only one major issue with
the film and you know don't worry no
spoilers there's an aspect to the movie
that I would have loved to have been
more ambiguous but it kind of lets you
know and I just wish that it said no you
guys figure that out for the next 30 40
50 years and argue about it forever I
wish that that was how things happened
during a certain sequence instead it's
like no this is what it is and I just I
like ambiguity and I wish that it was a
little more ambiguous and really other
than that I think this is a extremely
well made horror movie a great second
film from Jordan Peele if he wants to
continue in the horror genre please do
it needs you it really does if you want
to make other films great I want to see
it I want to say anything that guy does
even if he makes a movie that maybe
isn't as good as these two that he's
made already in in the future I
guarantee it'll be interesting I
guarantee it'll be something that you'll
want to see just because he made it I'm
gonna give us an a-minus I don't like
comparing but just for the sake of this
video I will get out is probably the
stronger film thematically but
is a better paced horror movie and it's
just like this pure horror film almost
from start to finish and in that aspect
i feel like i'll rewatch us many more
times plus i want to because it kind of
begs you to do that
so I'm very excited for more people to
see the movie and I'm just excited for
horror as a genre right now guys thank
you so much as always for watching look
forward to more reviews very soon and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]